well when russia invaded ukraine it also
outlawed the reporting of so-called
false information about its military the
punishment can be up to 15 years in
prison as a result many journalists fled
the country but that has not stopped
journalists and activists from trying to
reach russian audiences with the truth
holly williams spoke to one russian in
exile on a mission
russia's invasion of its neighbor has
been vicious
ukrainian civilians cut down on the
street
and in their homes
but what do ordinary russians know about
the war that was started by their
president vladimir putin
in russia television is state controlled
with current affairs shows following the
kremlin's line
ukraine's leaders and nazis who need to
be eradicated says this guest russia is
not just fighting ukraine but also the
values of the west says another
commentator with russia on the side of
justice and salvation so to own a media
operation in russia you have to be a
putin crony is that right no absolutely
yeah you have to be loyal ilya
ponamariov was not loyal to vladimir
putin he's a former member of russia's
duma or parliament who was forced into
exile after voting against russia's
annexation of crimea in 2014. he told us
many russians have been willingly
brainwashed
and actually believe their military is
liberating ukraine because the truth is
painful ukraine is being controlled by
the west ukrainians are being zombified
by neo-nazis and we want to liberate
them
and
that's what majority of the population
actually thinks because nobody wants to
understand that we are the fascists of
today
and that's such an inconvenient truth
it's hard for russians just as it's hard
for people in most countries to accept
that their country is doing something
that might be morally wrong absolutely
and
you are americans you were not accepting
the same thing when you were fighting in
vietnam for example or in iraq but the
u.s media is free to report on the
reality of america's wars while doing so
in russia can be illegal
that's why ponamariov has set up this
online news channel broadcasting in
russian from ukraine
giving russians an unfiltered account of
the war they claim to have around a
million viewers
ponomariov believes ukraine will win the
war
and the invasion will ultimately be
putin's downfall
there would be popular uprising in
russia because
all of the putin's might and influence
and power is coming from his alpha
male image so if he is losing
then means that he is weak and he was he
would be overturned
there are many who disagree with poner
mariov's prediction but he points out
that very few expected the soviet union
to crumble as quickly as it did in 1991
and if you recall one of the things that
contributed to the collapse of the ussr
was its disastrous invasion of
afghanistan for cbs morning's holly
williams dinetro ukraine
once again great reporting from holly
williams in ukraine